a Japanese company is taking a lot of
heat for manufacturing and selling these
childlike sex dolls which they claim
would help pedophiles not abuse real
children by giving them essentially a
doll as an alternative this is a company
called trot la and they're manufacturing
these life-sized dolls they are
anatomically correct if you folks
understand what I mean
and they imitate girls as young as five
years old and they're being sold to
pedophiles around the world they promote
more than 100 different models of
imitation girls dolls they can be
dressed in lace or leather lingerie or
completely naked I I'm feeling a little
bit nauseous as I tell the story I do
have to admit the founder of the company
shin takagi is a self-confessed
pedophile and he defended the product
saying these products help pedophiles to
channel and control their sexual urges
and the dolls can be used to keep
pedophiles away from actually doing
anything to kids this really relates to
a lot a lot a lot of research into this
issue and there are many people and I've
read a lot of interviews with people who
say I am a pedophile in the sense that I
have what is considered by some to be a
psychiatric condition whereby I feel
sexually aroused by prepubescent
children I cannot control the fact that
I am aroused by that what I can control
is my actions and this is something that
often comes up when talking about you
know there's this famous real doll which
is an adult anatomically correct
imitation woman and sometimes people
will say well the real dolls if you give
them to would-be rapists it'll reduce
the number of real world rapes and many
people believe that that's not true
because that that would only hold true
if violent rape is about is a sexual act
and as many of us realize violent rape
is much more of a violent act than it is
a sexual act and in many cases is about
power so really having sex with a doll
is not likely to drastically reduce the
incidents of rape however and I know
Rachel you've looked into this quite a
bit we may be talking about a different
situation when it comes to pedophilia
and there are many who think that this
actually could reduce the instance of
pedophiles going out and actually
abusing children I don't know how you
feel well if you look at kind of prior
treatment treatment practices they've
actually proved to be largely
ineffective and they have also shown
that they have not changed the sexual
orientation of people towards children
and their recidivism rates for people
who aren't pedophiles has been about 10
to 50 percent so Parrott of lehigh in
other ways which is comparatively high
so if I'm thinking about this doll in
terms of a treatment option I don't I
can't really imagine how it would be
that effective or would change anyone's
preferences if they're having this
access right in front of them yeah I
mean to some extent uh I don't know I
mean I I guess I can imagine how in the
short term an individual if they had one
of these childlike sex dolls would say
okay today the childlike sex doll is
going to keep me home and not out being
a predator to a real world child but
like rachel is saying we know that this
there has really been no effective way
to make someone who is who is seems to
be predisposed to like little kids
sexually eliminate that predisposition
and with such a high recidivism rate I'm
more focused not on the morality of this
but on the practicality and I'm it's a
pretty big question mark for me I feel
it's kind of like you know drugs in that
a drug addict while they put them on
this other drug that's gonna help them
in a short term they're still addicted
of drugs they're sure using methadone
versus methadone or narcan being used
suboxone etc exactly i I think it's the
same thing that no matter what when
either they run out of money or the DA
breaks or the dollar gets stolen they're
still gonna you know go back to this
recidivism that we talked about it and
it's still gonna be a problem at the end
well if we want to use the drug analogy
Rachel there are people who do
successfully kick drug addiction through
something like methadone I mean it's
very it's seen very negatively in many
ways and the lack of that the failure
rate is very very high as Jason
is correctly alluding to but it does
actually work for some people who then
when they are around drugs they say you
know I remember what it was like in my
life and even though I have a
predisposition to addiction to drugs I'm
not gonna fall back into it could it be
that the availability of these dolls
could in some people create a similar
sort of paradigm I really don't know I
think it could go one of two ways
because I think for some people it could
be a very cathartic outlet for them and
that sounds like a very strange thing to
say when you're talking about a sex doll
or something being a cathartic outlet
but in another sense what what happens
when the doll isn't enough and it brings
up this kind of inflammatory response
when they're saying okay I have this
this doll but it's not responding to me
and what happens when they need
something more that thought alone is
kind of terrifying yeah I guess I just
don't know if the I I know that the real
doll analogy for preventing violent rape
is not very good because really as I
said rape is about power and violence
rather than sexuality and you're not
going to be able to sort of meet that
desire or or so what I guess desire is
the right word with a real doll maybe
there is something to this and I also
think what Rachel's alluding to which is
what if what if these dolls fuel the
interest in committing real-world acts
of of sexual assault on children I I
just don't know
yeah I think it opens a Pandora box that
you don't really want to go down but at
the same time you know well this is
America you got to let people do what
they want and Kyle this is Japan but no
this is Japan but at the same time I
assume yes UMI's are gonna come to the
United States at some point and you just
have to catch people doing bad things
when they do it that's kind of the state
of affairs our video our video games
then violent video games an outlet fort
for young children who want to kind of
express these violent tendencies in that
is a can of worms that is widely studied
right and they're the the best there's
two opposite camps on that one which
says violence in video games and movies
consumed by children and we can say
children very young or more like
adolescent post puberty age has no
impact whatsoever on real
violence there are others who seem to
think the line is very direct you can
take a completely nonviolent kid have
them play some violent video games next
thing you know he's going to be in the
real world to shooting people up what I
believe based on a number of interviews
we've done is that exposure to a variety
of types of violence in individuals who
are already predisposed to violence
conservative flip a switch and this can
include it could include violent video
games
it could include violent movies but it
also can just include violence at home
seeing domestic violence being the
victim of domestic violence etc and and
very often the focus is just on video
games per se and that I think there's
very often that idea is completely
oversimplified